[Music]
well of course you know China in the
u.s. a very different ideas about
intellectual property lights right about
copying and things like that imitation
I'm going to very foundationally things
that in the US are completely taboo in
China might be wrong or maybe even not
legal but they're not taboo right and we
can address a whole why is that you know
why is is building a building that looks
just like a chateau in France you know
why did we not do that here in the West
but you know we might do it being an
amusement park it'd be something good
yes you did it was you know it's tacky
right so why do we think it's tacky
we're in the East are considered I'm
fine so you know you can have a very
elaborate copy of a French chateau you
can pour 50 million dollars into it you
can use the exact stone that they used
in the original and you know it have
this copy in every way perfect and in
China that's seen as a great thing right
like no one would say you're kidding you
said 50 million dollars on this copy in
the US we would never do that
right and why is that it's because we
have two different models of self quite
the contrary
you know if it sees something which is
great it's a small I'll do that too you
know it's omage and this goes right down
to the educational level I mean so the
idea you know in our education we're
very much trying to coax out of people
you know their unique vision right it
you know in Asia the idea that actually
there are many great ideas kind of out
out there all around you in your culture
and that may be before you think about
how you can put your own stamp on things
maybe you should absorb those ideas it's
very important so things that to us you
know you just don't do you know to them
it's like well why not
you know network for playful attitude
and we'll say toward these things and so
in order to absorb those ideas well how
do you do that often you imitate right
so painters start they they find a great
painter
the painter with whom they feel
simpatico and they they copy those
paintings and what
what are they doing now we think of
copying we think of the kind of
mechanical process but actually they're
trying to internalize the greatness of
this painting so it's to them it's not
it's not of mechanical process an
organic process you know they're taking
in this influence ultimately they want
to add to the great tradition that they
have signed up for and ultimately they
want their their contribution to be
theirs and you know to be singular but
they see that is coming after they have
mastered their great tradition right and
mastering it through imitation through
memorization is completely fine and like
I say it's a sign of homage now you can
only imagine a culture where there is
this very long-standing tradition of
education through imitation and through
copying you can only imagine a company
to take a tradition like that and to
sort of say to this culture well
actually every time you imitate
something that's actually taboo I mean
they get it intellectually you can tell
them but very foundationally that's not
who they are and that's not you know
these are not ideas but they have had it
were you're telling us like every time
you pick up a spoon you know that that's
going to compromise it yeah you really
should pay a little see every time you
use that spoon maybe just think that
well that is really very strange right
so I think that when we look at these
ideas we see a very big foundational
split between the two cultures and if
you know I really copying is only one of
the many areas where you see very
divergent ideas
[Music]